Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家预告一件目前正在进行、非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造能够为你带来收益的收入源，而不是不断地用时间去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢“通往持续收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge），这是由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是一个有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, we are looking at two more ways to maximize your brilliance and to help your vibrancy shine to yourself and to
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的精美奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有详细信息发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客节目中，我们将探讨另外两种方法，以最大限度地发挥你的才华，并帮助你的活力向你自己以及向
those around you to help you on this career of yours and to, you know, help you be the best you can be along the way. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. We are fast approaching application season, which we're expecting, certainly for clinical psychology to open sometime close to the start of September. But the Clearinghouse do sometimes like to throw spanners in the works. So don't worry, I'll be here with you every step of the way. And I'll be here for free as well with the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, but also with the free Compassionate Q&A series too. You can join me on Monday, the 4th of September 2023 at 6pm. You can also join me on Tuesday, the 3rd of October 2023 at 6pm. And for the final time in application series this year
周围的人展现出来，帮助你走好这段职业生涯，并在这一过程中助你成为最好的自己。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我们正迅速接近申请季，我们预计，临床心理学专业肯定会在9月初左右开放。不过，结算所（Clearinghouse）有时喜欢搞点突发状况。所以别担心，我会一路陪伴着你。而且我会通过《有抱负的心理学家》播客免费陪伴你，同时也会通过免费的“富有同情心的问答”（Compassionate Q&A）系列节目陪伴你。你可以在2023年9月4日星期一晚上6点加入我的直播。你还可以在2023年10月3日星期二晚上6点加入我。并且今年申请季的最后一次直播，
you can also catch me Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm live across all of my socials Dr Marianne Trent feel free to just watch Soak Up The Goodness listen to me answer other people's questions or pop along and ask me your questions as well. And if you'd welcome some more support during application season or just generally in your development, do consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month as well. Right, let's have a look at the first of our tips for today. So the first is something that I found really useful during the pandemic. So at that time, I was working in the NHS, but also working in private practice, also being a mother and trying to homeschool. And so there was quite a
你还可以在2023年11月7日星期二晚上6点在我的所有社交平台上观看我的直播，我是玛丽安·特伦特。欢迎随时来观看、汲取干货、听我回答其他人的问题，或者顺便过来问我你的问题。如果你希望在申请季获得更多支持，或者在你的个人发展中获得一般性的支持，不妨考虑加入《有抱负的心理学家》会员群，每月仅需 30 英镑起即可加入。好了，让我们来看看今天的第一个小贴士。所以第一点是我在疫情期间觉得非常有用的一招。当时，我在 NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作，同时也经营着私人诊所，还要当妈妈并尝试在家教育孩子。所以当时有相当多的
lot of stress going on. At that time, even leaving the house felt really like you were dicing with the possibility of death it really felt very difficult so going out and working in the NHS whilst going shopping and trying to run a household and trying to manage my two children under a not particularly massive roof was a real struggle and so one of the things that I found really helpful was to take some time in the mornings before everything started. So for me, my sort of mindfulness and stress reducing practices took the form of 10 minutes of yoga each morning. So there's a brilliant program that you can access for not that much money called Yoga Burn run by a lady called Zoe and so the first one in the series you watch three times so I would do on a Monday morning a Wednesday morning and a Friday morning and then there's a really nice sort of
压力。那时，甚至离开家门都让人感觉像是在与死亡的可能擦肩而过，真的感觉非常困难。所以，一边在 NHS 工作，一边去购物、试图维持一个家庭的运转，还要在一个并不算特别大的屋檐下照顾我的两个孩子，这真是一场真正的挣扎。因此，我发现非常有帮助的一件事，就是在每天一切开始之前抽出一些时间。对我来说，我的正念和减压练习形式是每天早晨 10 分钟的瑜伽。有一个非常棒的项目，你不需要花很多钱就能访问，叫做“瑜伽燃烧”（Yoga Burn），由一位叫佐伊（Zoe）的女士运营。这个系列中的第一个视频你需要看三遍，所以我会在周一早晨、周三早晨和周五早晨做，然后还有一个非常好的、
stretchy cool down one on a Sunday and so the next week you'd then do series two on a Monday, Wednesday and Friday and then do the the nice stretchy relaxing one on a Sunday and I think it lasted about eight weeks and so it was a really nice way for me to spend a little bit of time being mindful, checking in with my body, seeing how it felt but also enjoying the sort of calm and stillness of my house before it all got rowdy and it all got busy. And there were demands placed upon me to do things, to give more, to do, do, do, do, do, either for my clients or for my children or for my husband for that matter, you know. So yeah, is there a space in your day where you could reclaim some time for yourself to be mindful, to connect with your body, maybe to do some yoga? And if you're listening to this and you're like, oh no, I don't think yoga's
适合拉伸和放松的环节在周日进行。接着在第二周，你会在周一、周三和周五做第二系列的练习，然后在周日做那个舒适拉伸放松的练习。我想这个项目持续了大约八周。这对我来说是一个非常好的方式，可以花一点时间进行正念冥想，与我的身体进行联结，看看它的感觉，同时也能在家里变得喧闹和忙碌之前，享受那种平静和安宁。而且当时有很多要求压在我身上，要去做事，要付出更多，要不停地做、做、做、做、做，无论是为了我的客户、我的孩子，还是为了我的丈夫。所以，是的，你的生活中有没有这样一个空间，你可以为自己重新夺回一些时间来做正念、与身体联结，也许做一些瑜伽？如果你正在听这个节目，心里想，哦不，我觉得瑜伽不
for me, have you tried it? Have you tried it? So yoga bone isn't traditional yoga, it's quite flowy, and it aims to get your heart rates up a little bit as well. But it certainly does help with your with your flexibility to and with your strength. So for me, I found that it was a really nice chance to just do 10 minutes of something because we haven't always got time in our days, especially when you're feeling really busy and squashed, to do half an hour, to do an hour, to do 90 minutes. But for me, I could find, you know, 10 minutes, four times a week. So I hope you will find that to be useful. It might just be that you do some progressive muscle relaxation before bed. It might just be that you do some
适合我，那你尝试过吗？你尝试过吗？“瑜伽燃烧”并不是传统的瑜伽，它相当流畅，并且也旨在让你的心率稍微升高一点。但它确实对你的柔韧性和力量有所帮助。对我有帮助的是，我发现这是一个非常好的机会，只需花 10 分钟做点什么，因为我们在日常生活中并不总是有时间——特别是当你感到非常忙碌和紧凑时——去抽出半小时、一小时、甚至 90 分钟。但对我来说，我可以找到每周四次、每次 10 分钟的时间。所以我希望你会发现这很有用。也许只是在睡前做一些渐进式肌肉放松。也许只是做一些
soothing rhythm breathing, something that is about you creating some calm in what might feel like chaos. Let's take a quick moment here to take a little break and I'll be back along very soon with the next of Marianne Summer soundbite tips. that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. So in the first half, we were looking at ways to carve out space for you to be mindful, for you to connect, calm and engage with your body and find some tranquility,
舒缓节奏的呼吸练习，这些都是关于你在看似混乱的环境中创造一些平静。现在让我们稍作休息，我很快就会带着玛丽安的下一个夏季精彩音频小贴士回来，这些贴士将帮助你获得资格认证。所以快来看看吧。它就在这本书里。《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。《临床心理学家合集》。欢迎回来。所以在前半部分，我们一直在探讨如何为你开辟空间来进行正念冥想，让你去联结、平静并让你的身体参与其中，找到一些宁静，
some, you know, some some still calm space for yourself it's so important and it's still something I do so when I go for runs I like that sense I'm not talking to anybody I'm just alone with my thoughts there's no there's no expectation that I'll do anything other than keep my feet moving and you know connect to the sounds of nature and I do also do a little bit of litter picking as I'm out and about it's called plogging which is when you jog but then you in between bins you pick up some litter and then pop it in the bin on your way past so So yes, could you plug? Join my revolution of plugging, pluggers. So the next of my top tips is thinking about your caseload. And if you hold a
一些，你知道的，一些平静安宁的空间给自己。这太重要了，而且这也是我一直在做的事情。所以当我跑步时，我喜欢那种感觉，我不跟任何人说话，我只是独自一人沉浸在思绪中，除了保持双脚移动之外，没有任何期望，你知道的，去联结大自然的声音。而且当我外出时，我也会顺便捡一些垃圾，这被称为“慢跑捡垃圾”（plogging），也就是你在慢跑时，在两个垃圾桶之间顺手捡起一些垃圾，然后在路过时把它扔进垃圾桶。所以，是的，你能去慢跑捡垃圾吗？加入我的慢跑捡垃圾革命吧，慢跑捡垃圾者们。我的下一个顶级建议是关于你的 caseload（工作量/服务对象名单）。如果你持有一份
caseload of clients that you see for therapy or even therapy groups or, you know, any kind of work that you do within the team, anything that might be on your job plan, you can kind of think about as your caseload. You know, who are those clients? If you're supervising staff, you can think about them as being on your job plan and potentially on your caseload as well. If we've got lots and lots of super demanding or super risky clients, then that can really take its toll on us. So a really useful conversation to have in supervision or in line management, if that's a separate service or function for you, is thinking about balancing your caseload. So thinking about
为你提供治疗的客户名单，甚至是治疗小组，或者，你知道的，你在团队中做的任何类型的工作，任何可能在你的工作计划（job plan）上的东西，你都可以认为这是你的工作量。你知道，那些客户都是谁？如果你在督导员工，你可以认为他们在你的工作计划中，也可能在你的工作量中。如果我们有很多很多要求极高或风险极高的客户，那真的会给我们带来沉重的负担。因此，在督导中或在直线管理中（如果对你而言这是个独立的部门或职能）进行一次非常有用的小型谈话，就是考虑平衡你的工作量。也就是说要考虑
when you're picking up new work actually I already have you know five complex cases um you know and this one sounds a little bit more simple could I put myself forward for this one and thinking about the importance of doing that and knowing that it's okay to do that and I guess it's similar to um one of the other um things of being boundary but it's it's it's more than that because you're literally looking at caseload management you're looking at well full up you're feeling right now you know whereas when you first took on the cases maybe you were more resilient maybe you were more well resourced or maybe it's the other way around you know when you first joined the team or when you first took on this caseload, maybe you're already feeling more full up. But now you're more into your stride or you're in a better place with your relationship or your course or training or your masters or, you know, your peers or your family.
当你接手新工作时，其实我已经有五个复杂病例了，嗯，而这个听起来稍微简单一点，我可以为这个病例自告奋勇吗？并思考这样做的重要性，知道这样做是可以的。我想这类似于设定边界的其他事情之一，但这更进了一层，因为你实际上在审视工作量管理，你在审视你现在感觉有多饱满，而当你最初接手这些病例时，也许你更有韧性，也许你拥有更多资源，或者情况恰恰相反，你知道，当你刚加入团队或刚接手这个工作量时，也许你已经觉得更满了。但现在你已经渐入佳境，或者在你的恋爱关系、课程、培训、硕士学位、同伴或家庭关系中处于一个更好的位置。
You now feel like you've got some more flexibility, some more space in your window of tolerance to be able to step that up a little bit. So it's a fluid process, I would say, that changes from day to day, week to week. But it's important that you're checking in with that, with your supervisor and with yourself. You know, if you find yourself dreading a particular client or a particular day because of the combination of clients or tasks that you've got could you look at that could you jiggle clients around to different days to spread a bit of the joy or a bit of the misery but of the things that you find useful engaging or depleting throughout the week and yeah just make sure you're looking after yourself because if you're not looking after yourself then you can't help to put those oxygen masks on other people hope you found today's episode useful i will be
你现在觉得你有了更多的灵活性，在你的容纳窗（window of tolerance）内有更多的空间，能够稍微加大一点工作强度。所以我想这是一个流动的过程，它会从一天到另一天、一周到另一周地发生变化。但重要的是，你要与你的督导以及你自己核对这一点。你知道，如果你发现自己因为客户或任务的组合而对某个特定的客户或特定的一天感到恐惧，你能不能审视一下？你能不能把客户调整到不同的日子，以便在一周中分散一点快乐，或者分散一点痛苦，分散那些你觉得有用、吸引人或消耗精力的东西？是的，确保照顾好你自己，因为如果你不照顾好你自己，你就无法帮助别人戴上氧气面罩。希望你觉得今天的节目有用。我将
back along with the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast from 6am on monday if you've got any ideas for what you would like to be covered in future episodes, do come and let me know by connecting with me on socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, or you can slip into the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group and tell me there, or even drop it in the YouTube comments. Please do like, subscribe, share, tell your friends about us, and I'll look forward to catching up with you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist
在周一早上 6 点带着《有抱负的心理学家》播客的下一期节目回归。如果你对未来节目中希望探讨的内容有什么想法，请通过在社交媒体上与我联系来告诉我。我到处都是 Dr. Marianne Trent，或者你可以潜入《有抱负的心理学家》社区免费 Facebook 群组并在那里告诉我，甚至在 YouTube 评论区留言。请务必点赞、订阅、分享，告诉你的朋友们关于我们的节目，我期待很快与你们交流。保重！如果你想成为一名心理学家，
then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格认证的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫加娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到这一目标的途径竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊讶，而且成为一名临床心理学家并没有唯一完美的方式，这让我充满信心，觉得我并没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。